Speaker 1: radical and repugnant.
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE
now has come up with the wild claim that Antifa
killed a police officer.
This is not true.
This took place during a recent hearing, LGBTQ
nation says Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE told Congress Antifa killed a cop.
She was dead wrong.
Police shot Manuel Teran 57 times.
GREENE said they're proof that leftists kill
cops.
Let's go to the hearing where Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is now wearing glasses, apparently
in an attempt to look more intelligent.
I don't know, Eddie.
Speaker 2: You want to talk about human lives?
Well, it seems to be that being a police officer
is a target for Antifa because they actually
murdered someone.
They are.
They actually murdered a place.
Oh, you don't know.
That's right.
Because you don't study left wing extremism
from your nonpartisan, so-called nonprofit.
But let me tell you about it.
There was a they a 26 year old activist was
the manual Teran shot and killed Georgia state
patrol trooper there.
That was this year.
You're right.
Not last year.
It was this year.
So left wing extremism is definitely on the
rise and murder is a big part of it.
Speaker 1: Okay.
That is false and misleading.
The individual she's referring to.
And it's not manual like your VCR Manual.
It's manual manual.
Iran was not a member of Antifa.
He was an environmental activist who opposed
the construction of a police training facility
in Atlanta.
He was killed by police officers who shot
57 times during a raid on the protest camp.
No police officer was killed in the incident.
It's not what?
It's not even a question of who did the killing.
No police officer was killed in the incident.
There was a state trooper injured by a gunshot.
It might have come from a fellow officer and
it might have come from the officer's own
firearm.
Okay.
That's a very different story to what Marjorie
Taylor GREENE told there.
So is she a liar?
Of course.
Is she dishonest?
Yeah.
Is she ignorant?
Absolutely.
Does she have no business in a position of
legislative power in the United States?
110%.
But it's also important to understand the
dangerous nature of how they inspire violence.
This is a form of stochastic terrorism, where
if you lie enough about the supposed it acts
of violence that are being committed by your
political opponents when they are not committing
such acts of violence, you in a way inspire,
legitimize or approve of signal approval for
your side continuing to to commit the acts
of violence that they are actually committing.
Remember, the overwhelming political violence
in the United States is right wing.
And then I mean, listen, we've talked about
this before, that the numbers, no matter how
you slice and dice them, are very clear.
And so this is not only all based on lies.
I would argue it is a form of stochastic terrorism
by Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
We will see whether these sorts of folks get
another swing at the ball.
I don't know what you want to call it, but
in 2024, we may see these sorts of folks made
a more permanent part of American politics,
or it may be the end of MAGA.
My hope is that 2024 is the end of MAGA.
I don't know that I will be correct.
A monday Memorial Day we will have our one
day membership special.
I would really love for you to become a member
on Memorial Day.
You know, we've been doing this show for a
long time, and as I've said before, we estimate
that somewhere between 0.7 and 0.9% of our
audience supports this financially.
That's fine.
We do the show quite literally for the 99.3%
that don't contribute, and we're glad to do
it.
It also is true if we were able to get a full
1% of our audience supporting our work or
even one and a half percent, it's a game changer,
the things we would be able to do.
So I would love for you to join the ranks
of membership.
Yes, you do get the daily bonus show when
you become a member.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show.
You want to make money.
Everybody else that makes money to fund themselves.
Speaker 1: As bad as you can see, Alex Jones
hates the bonus show.
But on Monday, Memorial Day will be blowing
out memberships at prices I can't even mention
out loud because it would just make my face
red.
So get on my newsletter at David Pacman dot
com and then Monday, Memorial Day, you'll
get an email.
It'll tell you what to do.
And we will do the thing.
The David Pacman Show continues to be an audience
supported program, which you can support if
you want.
Listen, if you don't want to support the show,
still available for free to everybody, we
produce it for everybody.
But if you are able to be part of the, you
know, roughly 0.8, 0.9% of the audience that
supports us financially, you can sign up at
join Pacman dot com.
And I think that that would be a beautiful
thing to do.